Billy crazy night beyond your wildest  dreams  I am good I am good but I can only  imagine how this moment must feel and  can you digest how do you how do you  take in this moment oh you don't know a  couple years from now will be like  remember that one time no you don't take  it in just to promote our music to make  sure that everybody gets a chance to  hear it you know go on tour with us the  work type wake way harder on tour than  we do there up to 5:00 in the morning  everyday everybody at Interscope dark  room just just championing us and  fighting for us and those are the people  that that's like  the youngest person ever to hit those  awards the moment enjoy the night the  picture without holding all those grand  [Music]